[Music]
all right let's go out to NOLA New
Orleans Louisiana and talk to Matt
what's up
Matt Matt you there hey Dr John can you
hear me yeah what's up man oh not too
much all right so I'll get right into it
I I need any kind of advice you can
offer on how to address the issue of my
daughter's mother allowing her access to
a smartphone so I can fill that in a
little a little bit more if you need yes
it sounds like the way you said my
daughter's mother sounds like y'all
aren't married yeah yeah unfortunately
we're divorced um my daughter is is 12
uh we share custody and aside from this
one massive issue we seem to be pretty
on the same page as far as our daughter
goes um except for this really one issue
and I've I've tried every kind of
conceivable approach that I could think
of to try to talk with her about it um
explained all of the potential dangers
and consequences of letting a
12-year-old have unfettered access to a
smartphone um there's even been two
incidents that it's already caused uh
one of which was more of a discipline
incident but the second one was um
pretty serious scare where our daughter
was potentially in some serious danger
if I hadn't caught it um and I don't
know nothing nothing seems to work to
try to get through to her and I I'm just
looking for what's her what's her excuse
man what I mean what is her response
when you give her all this info uh well
um the most recent what because uh the
most recent one was just she her
behavior was good and she earned it back
so uh after the major scare I uh agreed
to a we agreed to a compromise where I
did plenty of homework and found a uh
Kids Safe phone with with some
sufficiently robust safety features that
I was satisfied with and uh she used
that for a while and then couple of
weeks ago I found out she just let her
have the smartphone back and when I
asked her about it she said oh well her
behavior in school was good so she
earned it um so here's what here's what
you're dealing with with you're dealing
with a woman who is so desperate for her
kids
approval and so desperate for her kid to
like
her and so desperate to avoid
confrontation with a 12-year-old that
she's willing to
sacrifice her psychological well-being
her emotional well-being or her body
image and um her physical and
psychological safety MH
not to mention um any future employer
who happens to get a written record of
idiotic things that 12 and 13 and 14 and
15 and 16 year olds say and photos they
take of themselves to boys who like
please please please please um she would
prefer to be
cool and prefer to be like you you hit
it right on the head because so listen
all of the data in the world doesn't
matter you're not you're not
you look man many many many many people
could solve type 2 diabetes in 90
days they
don't millions and millions of people
could lower their risk of lung cancer by
quitting smoking they
don't you're not dealing with an
information um deprivation you're
dealing with a very insecure adult who
is allowing the her 12-year-old daughter
to prop up her emotional regulation mhm
and I hate that for you yeah so I would
stop going to war with with my ex-wife
because you're not it's there's no one
wins this
yeah I would do the best I could to put
those little I Spy Apps I don't know
what they're all called where you can
see your where your daughter's going
maybe but that's I mean that's a losing
proposition kids are just too smart oh I
I fully understand that one um and I
also say this um
my my sons most of his friends have
phones yeah and when they come to our
house we don't allow kids to have phones
and there's this really rad thing all
the parents are all in all of them when
they walk into our house they hand my
wife their smartphone and my wife just
puts it keeps it and tells all the
parents if you all need one of your kids
text me and I'll I'll get them and the
parents love it and you know who else
loves it the kids love it
so yeah when she's at Mom's house she's
got her phone she's at your house there
is no phones period
mhm and she she will kick and scream
because those things are so addictive
and they are their Lifeline to their
friend communities and they are their
Lifeline to everything and the parents
are adult the adult world has failed
these kids but that's where we are and
so just prepare for her to be mad but
she's not mad at you she's mad that her
body is screaming at her because you've
cut off her Supply yeah okay yep and by
the way when she's over with you you're
going to to put your phone away
too absolutely I hate this for you
dude yeah yeah I mean I think it goes
without saying that my my biggest fear
is that it's going to take something
massive happening before you know the
realization hits that oh this this is a
bad idea I actually don't think that
would solve
it because you can look at the child
predator um numbers in this country and
the trafficking numbers in this country
and how quick um
Predators just
swarm like ants to chat rooms with 12
and 13 and 14 year old girls doesn't
matter parents don't care they still
hand their kids a phone it's insane it's
insane absolutely I I I work I I I deal
with that in my line of work so I I'm
very I'm very familiar with with all of
it
yeah man okay yeah there's not a thing
man there's just I mean
your daughter could get I don't want to
I don't put I don't want put things out
into the universe your daughter could
get way over her head yeah and she would
have the phone back in four
months three months yeah that that's
basic that's basically what happened I
mean what did she do if you don't mind
me asking I mean she was in serious
danger of getting groomed she was
talking I caught her talking to some
stranger that she met online that
claimed to be claimed to be a boy her
age but you know how that works um
fortunately uh she she didn't send any
kind of inappropriate pictures or
anything like that but uh this time I
mean it was the it was there was classic
groomer style language and and there
were pictures that were sent to her of
supposedly the person she was talking to
that was pictures of a a young boy but I
mean you know you know how that works
yeah but here's the thing already
stamped inside of
her
um already stamped on the inside on the
inside of her chest right by her heart
is how alive she felt when that boy that
fake boy was telling her how pretty she
was and how smart she was and there will
come a moment when she's 16 that she
goes chasing that again yeah and she
might not send photos when she's 12 and
she's 16 it's a different game she's 17
that's a different game she's 18 that's
a different game and moms and dads if
you think I'm
playing I've just done too many sexual
assault investigations at the University
level
I've had sat with too many young college
students who explain to me what happened
to them in high school I'm telling you
and you keep doing it anyway you keep
doing it anyway dude now you got me all
fired up Matt oh yeah yeah I mean like I
said I deal I deal with it almost every
day in my line of work uh I deal with
you know that kind of stuff so I'm well
familiar with with all of it and so
that's why it's my that's my biggest
fear so she's going to be here's the
workaround there's not a workaround
here's the reality that you have to
choose to live into okay okay it means
sitting down with your 12-year-old
daughter and being incredibly
explicit if somebody asks you to take a
picture of yourself don't and please let
a grownup know and if you don't trust me
and you don't trust your mom trust Miss
so and so I actually told my daughter
the other day I have kind of a a I don't
want to say frequent but a quiet
check-in just as using professional
skills I just happened to be her dad but
I said and you remember if you don't
want to tell me and Mom you can tell
Miss beath You can tell Miss Rachel
and my daughter said ah Dad I
know but I think you sit down and be
very clear about hey honey I deal with
my
job old men trick young girls into
sending pictures of them without their
shirts on without their clothes
on and it feels
scary and it feels exciting and it
feels a little bit
dangerous and it's really really
scary never even if you know that's your
boyfriend on the other line he can
screenshot that photo maybe show her an
example of a screenshot and he'll have
it to show his friends forever never do
that please never do that and I think
you have to get very very explicit
obviously she's 12 so it Be age
appropriate don't be a weirdo but um I
think that explicitness moves up uh it
becomes increasingly more direct as she
gets older um as she head to eighth
grade and high school and Beyond but
dude I'm sorry I'm sorry your wife's not
not like no way I didn't know that she
knows she knows she's too insecure to
look at her 12-year-old daughter and say
I'm your mom and I love you so much I
refuse to open the hounds of hell inside
your house and inside your bedroom and
inside your head I'm not going to do it
my job's to protect you instead she Ed
her phone and said here every creeper in
the world on planet Earth best of luck
to
you unbelievable man sorry Matt
sorry